a lot goes into raiding a film the
Motion Picture Association of America
thoroughly reviews upcoming releases to
see if they contain content generally
deemed inappropriate for younger
audiences dirty jokes mature themes
graphic violence and gratuitous nudity
can all earn a film in our rating
letting parents know they probably don't
want to bring the whole family for the
most part this system works well but it
definitely isn't perfect as highlighted
by the standout cases of super scary
movies that somehow avoided an r-rating
Weegee origin of evil from director Mike
Flanagan 2016's Ouija origin of evil
reveals the blood-chilling events that
occurred before the first Ouija film it
follows single mom Alice as she runs a
sham psychic business out of her home
with her daughter's Paulina and Doris
when Alice brings a Ouija board into the
mix in an effort to liven up her act
with some supernatural flair the three
women unwittingly make contact with an
evil spirit Ouija origin of evil shiz
away from gore but it maintains a
constant sense of dread delivering
violent deaths a freaky demonic
possession and enough horrifying images
to keep you wide awake at night just
like we couldn't believe this prequel
was actually a solid film following its
vapid predecessor we're also stunned it
snuck into theaters without an R rating
the last thing you feel it's cold mama
2013's mama stars Jessica Chastain as
Annabelle in Nikolaj coster-waldau as
her boyfriend Lucas and follows Lucas's
young nieces Victoria and Lily and the
ghostly figure they call mama that looms
over them when Lucas and Annabelle bring
Victoria and Lily home after they spent
five years in isolation following their
mother and father's deaths mama extends
her monstrous maternal hand beyond the
girl's reach to grip the lives of those
around them
Mama's eerie imagery tints and terror
filled story and haunting ending gives
us a case of the heebie-jeebies usually
reserved for r-rated fare Howard skated
by on a pg-13 instead we'll never fully
understand
insidious Patrick Wilson and Rose Byrne
lead mm pins insidious as married couple
Josh and Renee Lambert who recently
moved into a new home with their three
children which should be a humble abode
instead becomes the center of their
nightmares as really bad things begin to
befall the Lambert's it all starts when
Josh and Renee's son Dalton slips into a
coma like state after he sees a figure
hiding in the Attic and it only gets
worse from there after Renee is attacked
and a bloody handprint is left on
Dalton's bed the Lambert's pack up and
moved to a new house but the spirits
haunting them persist a demonic Darth
Maul looking into these stalks the
family of five and viewers soon learned
the real reason for Dalton's
unconsciousness and the startling truth
behind Josh's identity insidious is
light on blood and guts but heavy on
creepy imagery psychological tension and
unsettling storylines which is why it's
so surprising that it didn't receive an
r-rating the last exorcism how did the
last exorcism the found-footage
possession pic that's appeared on many a
scariest horror films lists lit by with
a pg-13 rating this genuinely eerie 2010
film begins with Reverend Cotton Marcus
embarking on what he thinks will be a
routine fake exorcism he's grown used to
performing here's just a taste of what
then goes down there's face slashing
animal killing and finger breaking there
are horrifying hooded figures
decapitations and people getting burned
alive and of course there's a possessed
girl who contorts into a human pretzel
and fills an already eerie barn with the
sounds of restrained demonic voice
[Music]
Oh drag me to help director Sam Raimi
returned to his horror roots with 2009's
drag me to hell the film begins as
mild-mannered bank loan officer
Christine Brown turns down her client
Sylvia's request for yet another
mortgage extension on the verge of
eviction Silvia crawls into the backseat
of Christine's car then attacks and
places a curse on her now haunted by a
soul starved spirit Christine's life
spirals into a blood-soaked horror show
she imagines flies buzzing and her
stomach experiences a projectile
nosebleed takes part in a demonic goat
sacrifice jumps into a grave to dig up a
corpse and gets embalming liquid pumped
into her mouth via a dead person's vomit
[Music]
featuring some of the most ferociously
gruesome gags in recent memory drag me
to hell is a hammy but horrifying
splatter fest that is somehow not rated
R the ring 2002's the ring is intensely
terrifying with a weird concept watch a
VHS tape and die seven days later it's
only made odder and more unsettling by
Helmer gore Verbinski's off-kilter
directorial choices dead bodies in the
disturbing videotape connect a handful
of Pacific Northwest teenagers to
journalist Rachel Keller who ventures to
find out the truth behind the killings
and see if she can escape the
unavoidable the entire film is filled
with grisly images most notably drowned
ghosts samara morgan emerging from a TV
screen and staggering across the floor
there's also a horse getting chopped to
pieces by the blades of a ferry
propeller plus some disembowelment and
ripped up fingernails for good measure
what ultimately pushes the ring into
should be r-rated territory is its
continuous sense of terror and
persistent disturbing imagery that leave
you with a feeling of dread you just
can't shake this 1975 Steven Spielberg
classic sees a gung-ho group of guys
journey into the big blue in search of
the man-eating great white shark that's
been terrorizing beachgoers on Hannity
island things go just about as well as
you'd anticipate they would in a shark
hunting venture the inclusion of many
brutal fatalities in the explosive shark
death makes JA
completely inappropriate for the team PG
rating it was given even though the MPAA
had at the time only PG or R to pick
when rating jaws before choice should
have been the latter
[Music]